[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de l'hexagone des
outre mer et de l'étranger je m'adresse
à vous ce soir alors que nous continuons
à nous battre contre le virus avec
détermination et que tout est fait pour
que la relance économique et sociale
soit la plus forte possible dans notre
pays parce qu'à quelques milliers de
kilomètres d'ici un tournant historique
est à l'oeuvre en afghanistan loin de
nos frontières mais avec des
conséquences majeures pour l'ensemble de
communauté internationale pour l'europe
et pour la france
après une guerre de vingt années après
la décision de retrait des troupes
américaines prises successivement par le
président trump et le président biden
kaboul la capitale de l'afghanistan est
tombé en quelques heures sans résistance
aux mains des talibans
l'intervention américaine et
internationale a commencé il ya
exactement vingt ans après les attentats
du 11 septembre 2001 et le refus du
régime taliban de l'époque en
afghanistan de livrer ben laden
l'organisateur de ces attentats notre
pays a été pendant treize années engagés
militairement en afghanistan
de 2001 à 2014 le président chirac dès
octobre 2001 a décidé la participation
de la france à l'action internationale
par solidarité avec nos amis et alliés
américains qui venait de subir une
attaque effroyable sur leur sol avec un
objectif clair combattre une menace
terroriste qui visait directement notre
territoire et celui de nos alliés depuis
l'afghanistan devenues le sanctuaire du
terrorisme islamiste à partir de juin
2011 le président nicolas sarkozy a
engagé le retrait des premières troupes
françaises le président françois
hollande a ensuite décidé du retrait
complet de nos troupes combattantes de
manière coordonnée avec les autorités
afghanes d'alors ainsi qu'avec nos
alliés
l'intervention militaire française a
donc définitivement cédé la place le 31
décembre 2014 à l'action civile que nous
avons continué de mener à bien auprès du
peuple afghan avec lequel nos liens
d'amitié sont anciens et profonds
en afghanistan notre combat était juste
et c'est l'honneur de la france 2 s'y
être engagée la france n'y a jamais eu
qu'un ennemi le terrorisme dans
interventions militaires n'ont pas
vocation en effet à se substituer à la
souveraineté des peuples ni à imposer la
démocratie de l'extérieur mais à
défendre la stabilité internationale et
notre sécurité
partout la mise en place de processus
politique crédible est notre priorité et
c'est ce principe fondamental de notre
politique étrangère que nous avons
appliqué en afghanistan et que nous
continuerons de mettre en oeuvre
mon nombre d'unités de l'armée française
sont passés dans ces vallées
durant ces treize années
légionnaires tirailleurs marsouins
chasseurs alpins marins aviateurs et
c'est à eux que je tiens d'abord ce soir
à m'adresser à ceux qui ont combattu aux
familles de ceux qui sont morts ou ont
été grièvement blessés nous n'oublierons
pas nos soldats
nous n'oublierons pas no more
90 au total
le 18 août 2008 dans l'embuscade d'uzbin
il y à 13 ans presque jour pour jour dix
soldats français et un interprète afghan
ont été tués
21 soldats français blessés
ce combat que la france a mené était
utile et était notre honneur il portera
un jour ses fruits je vous demande de
vous en souvenir
à cet instant la situation en
afghanistan se dégrade rapidement et
brutalement à l'heure où je vous parle
les talibans sont maîtres de la quasi
totalité du pays ils sont entrés dans
kaboul et contrôler la ville à
l'exception de l'aéroport où les
activités sont coordonnées par les
américains le président afghan a quitté
le pays les vols commerciaux ont cessé
ce tournant auquel nous étions préparés
nécessite des décisions et des
initiatives immédiate à la mesure de la
gravité de la situation pour répondre à
la catastrophe humanitaire
l'urgence absolue est de mettre en
sécurité nos compatriotes qui doivent
tous quitté le pays ainsi que les
afghans qui ont travaillé pour la france
non ressortissants ont été programmés
progressivement évacués en anticipation
ces dernières semaines nous sommes en
contact avec tous les français qui
veulent rejoindre le sol national qu'ils
se trouvent à l'aéroport militaire à
l'aéroport civil ou sur le site
historique de l'ambassade où la
situation demeure préoccupante
je veux ici remercier nos représentants
sur place nos diplomates policiers
militaires pour leur engagement et leur
courage
remercier aussi nos alliés américains
indispensable pour mener à bien ces
évacuations
la france est l'un des très rares pays à
avoir décidé de maintenir sur place
jusqu'au bout les moyens de protéger
ceux qui ont travaillé pour elle nous
avons aussi anticiper les opérations
d'évacuation dans les dernières semaines
tous les employés afghans des structures
françaises qui pouvait être menacés
ainsi que leurs familles ce qui
représente plus de 600 personnes ont
ainsi pu être accueillis et pris en
charge dans de bonnes conditions dans
notre pays la france protège en ce
moment le délégué de l'union européenne
et à apporter protection aux
collaborateurs afghan de la
représentation européenne la france a
également apporté protection et soutien
à tous les personnels français
d'organisations non gouvernementales
souhaitant quitter le pays
des opérations sont conduites depuis
plusieurs années pour accueillir en
france les personnels civils afghans qui
ont travaillé pour l'armée française
ainsi que leurs familles c'est notre
devoir et notre dignité de protéger ceux
qui nous aident interprète chauffeurs
cuisiniers et tant d'autres près de 800
personnes sont d'ores et déjà sur le sol
français plusieurs dizaines de personnes
sont encore sur place qui ont aidé
l'armée française et pour lesquels nous
restons pleinement mobilisés
de nombreux afghans défenseur des droits
artistes journalistes militants sont
aujourd'hui menacées en raison de leur
engagement nous les aiderons parce que
c'est l'honneur de la france d'être
côtés de celles et ceux qui partagent
nos valeurs autant que nous pourrons le
faire et en tenant compte de la
nécessaire adaptation de notre
dispositif
je remercie les associations collectifs
et communes qui aideront à leur accueil
afin de procéder à ces opérations
d'évacuation qui se conduiront pas sans
une étroite coordination avec les
militaires américains sur place j'ai
décidé l'envoi de deux avions militaires
et de nos forces spéciales ils seront
sur place dans les prochaines heures
au-delà de l'urgence
j'entends prendre au nom de la france
plusieurs initiatives en lien étroit
avec les autres états européens et nos
alliés notre action visera à continuer
de lutter activement contre le
terrorisme islamiste sous toutes ses
formes des groupes terroristes sont
présents en afghanistan et chercheront à
tirer profit de la déstabilisation le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
devra donc apporter une réponse
responsable et unis j'ai échangé sur ce
point avec le premier ministre johnson
et nous prendrons des initiatives
communes dans les prochaines heures le
retour de la stabilité passera par une
telle action politique et diplomatique
au sein du conseil de sécurité
l'afghanistan ne doit pas redevenir le
sanctuaire du terrorisme qu'il a été
c'est un enjeu pour la paix la stabilité
internationale contre un ennemi commun
le terrorisme et ceux qui le soutiennent
à cet égard nous feront également tout
pour que la russie les états unis et
l'europe puisse efficacement coopérer
car nos intérêts sont bien les mêmes
ensuite la déstabilisation de
l'afghanistan risque également
d'entraîner des flux migratoires
irréguliers vers l'europe la france
comme je les dis fait et continuera de
faire son devoir pour protéger celles et
ceux qui sont les plus menacés
nous prendrons toute notre part dans le
cadre d'un effort international organisé
est juste mais l'afghanistan aura aussi
besoin dans les temps qui viennent de
ses forces vives et l'europe ne peut pas
à elle seule assumer les conséquences de
la situation actuelle nous devons
anticiper et nous protéger contre des
flux migratoires irréguliers important
qui mettrait en danger ceux qui les
empruntent et nourrirait les trafics de
toute nature nous porterons donc en lien
avec la république fédérale d'allemagne
je me suis entretenu il ya quelques
instants à ce sujet avec la chancelière
merkel et avec d'autres états européens
une initiative pour construire sans
attendre une réponse robuste coordonnée
et unie qui passera par la lutte contre
les flux irréguliers la solidarité dans
l'effort l'harmonisation des critères de
protection et la mise en place de
coopérations avec les pays de transit et
d'accueil comme le pakistan la turquie
ou l'iran
enfin il nous faut continuer de défendre
nos principes nos valeurs qui font ce
que nous sommes
l'histoire de l'afghanistan n'a pas
commencé en 2001 nous sommes intervenus
dans un pays ébranlé par quarante ans de
guerre un grand pays tourmenté et nous
français sommes à même de le comprendre
nous à qui il a fallu des siècles de
luttes de faute d'avancées et de reculs
pour bâtir une nation conformes aux plus
grande espérance humaine l'égalité sans
considération d'origine de sexe ou de
religion et la liberté de choix et de
conscience et nous savons combien ces
combats sont chaque jour à recommencer
les défis auxquels les afgans et des
afghans seront confrontés dans les
prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois sont terribles immense le peuple
afghan a le droit de vivre dans la
sécurité et le respect de chacun les
femmes afghanes ont le droit de vivre
dans la liberté et la dignité et si le
destin de l'afghanistan est entre ses
mains nous resterons fraternellement aux
côtés des afghanes des afghans en
soutenant la société civile afghane et
en faisant notre devoir de protection de
celles et ceux que nous pouvons protéger
en disant très clairement à ceux qui
optent pour la guerre l'obscurantisme et
la violence aveugle qu'ils font le choix
de l' isolement en étant toujours du
côté de ceux qui combattent pour la
liberté les droits des femmes qui
portent dans le monde le même message
que le nôtre c'est le choix de la raison
c'est le choix de ce que nous sommes pro
fondée mans
vive la république et vive la france